thierry bordeaux et le maire de saint
loup sur semouse depuis dix ans fils
d'un ouvrier de chez parisot cinq frères
et soeurs il voit ses usines abandonnées
avec un pincement au coeur
sentiment que c'est que c'est du gâchis
c'est aussi une partie de la vie david
et des familles locales qui ont
contribué au développement de la stature
moi j'ai des frères qui ont travaillé
dans cette cuisine donc ont donné de
leur fureur de leur temps de ne voir
cette cette friche industrielle c'est ça
fait mal au mal aux tripes
mondialisation d industrialisation
fermetures d'usinés cette commune a été
frappé de plein fouet les chiffres sont
cruels 23 % des habitants sont au
chômage et 48 % n'ont aucun diplôme
[Musique]
oui c'est une réalité après voilà c'est
ses sens d'intérêt bassin industriel oc
on en a pas les seuls à avoir avoir
cette si caractéristique qu'on peut dire
de pauvreté quelque part c'est pas je
pense qu'il faut pas se cacher derrière
les mots il n'y a pas pas de dénier à
voir il ya une difficulté sociale qui
est importante
signe de cette pauvreté le succès de
l'épicerie solidaire lancée par la
mairie début décembre
ici les bénéficiaires paient leurs
courses un peu il était quand même je
vous rajoute ça suffit face à la forte
demande l'épicerie a ouvert ses portes
un deuxième après midi par semaine entre
nous ça nous permet aussi de détecter
ces problèmes autres que l'alimentaire
et puis aussi de pouvoir à l'avenir
concrétiser des actions des projets en
lien de seulement accepté pichery qui
sera un moteur pour l'accompagnement sur
la fente et l'accompagnement sur
l'insertion l'accompagnement sur la
culture
on a des personnes qui adorent lui mais
qui disent nous on n'a pas de vivre on a
une médiathèque est ouverte flamand ific
la nouvelle médiathèque la voilà elle a
trouvé sa place dans le hameau durable
composé de ces modules en bois
il y habite aussi depuis un an cinq
personnes âgées de la commune
est ce que vous vous plaisez ici oh oui
parce que j'ai la tranquillité c'est
bien parce que chez plat jeux furent
tous furent tirés bordeaux avait tant
besoin loger des personnes âgées dans
des appartements adaptés et une
ressource la forêt d'où ces modules en
bois
c'est là où on a besoin en milieu rural
quand on parle une idée d' a besoin et
où on a des ressources
mais pour assembler les choses on n'est
que des études avec notre propre culture
nounou connaissance limitée
l'état son rôle à jouer les
collectivités territoriales ont leur
rôle à jouer d'accompagnement des
communes qui prennent l'initiative de
tenter des choses
accompagné avec de la matière grise et
aussi avec des subventions
c'est ce que fait l'état avec le label
petite ville de demain obtenu par saint
loup objectif l'habitat la
redynamisation du centre-ville la
culture le tourisme l'économie locale
les projets ne manquent pas thierry
bordeaux veut s'appuyer sur une
ressource qui a déjà fait la richesse de
saint loup le bois actuellement la forêt
nos forêts sont vendus partent à
l'étranger sont transformés en produits
finis et reviennent bien souvent en
france de nombreux gaz un prêtre acheté
par part nous toute la valeur ajoutée de
fabrication transformation et partir
extérieur donc on n'a rien concerné est
le paris des années qu'ils vont dire
c'est que cette richesse puissent être
conservées sur le territoire là champs
de recherche et de développement qui est
important à développer là une
perspective moi je crois fermement sens
le bois pour de l'habitat avec ses
modules le bois pour fabriquer des
meubles très design saint lô a encore de
la ressource